hi I'd like to show you a cool new way
to create interactive tutorials that you
can run right inside the cloud shell
environment so to start with let's take
a look at this github repo under Google
cloud platform slash cloud - L -
tutorials
now this repo contains a file called
tutorial MD which is a markdown
specification of the desired structure
and flow for my tutorial let's look at
the underlying markdown syntax there we
see a few things there's one top-level
header and this defines the title of my
tutorial and then there's a sequence of
second-level headers where each second
level header corresponds to a discrete
step in my tutorial the rest of the file
contains the usual markdown syntax
formatting like highlighting code
snippets and command lines and things
like that there are also a few special
commands like this walkthrough editor
open file what this does is it generates
a hyperlink in the tutorial which when
clicked will automatically open that
specified file from the current repo in
the cloud shell editor so that's kind of
roughly the syntax of one of these
tutorials let's see it actually running
live so we'll go back up to the top
level and then the readme for this repo
I have a hyperlink coded which runs that
exact file so what this does is it
specifies the cloud shell URL it tells
the system which repo I would like
automatically cloned it says I'd like
the cloud shell editor enabled by
default and the new piece here is this
tutorial equals parameter which defines
a file in this repo to be interpreted as
a tutorial in markdown so we're
directing it at the tutorial MD file we
just looked at let's click on that link
and see what happens
so it's warning me it's about to Auto
clone a repo into my environment it
instantiates to shell clones that repo
starts up the cloud shell editor with
that all the files in that repo as a
project
and it automatically started my tutorial
on the right hand side of the screen as
you can see I have my title and my steps
that I can go forward and backward
through it highlights some of the syntax
like this echo command you get an
automatic button to copy that to the
clipboard which I can then paste into a
cloud shell so a lot of nice authoring
capabilities there and I also have those
special integrated directives I told you
about for example if you wanted to
direct somebody to click on this web
preview button rather than kind of
direct them there through imagery or
instructions you can generate one of
these URL or one of these hyperlinks
which when clicked will automatically
spotlight that portion of the screen as
you go through to the end you can even
generate a little widget that gets
feedback from the user as to what their
experience was like with the tutorial
one last thing I want to show you is
that you can actually run these
tutorials right from the shell and what
I'm going to do is finish the tutorial
close it and then invoke it again from
over here all I had to do was run cloud
show launch tutorial - D for developer
mode and then the file in this current
environment that I want - to be the
specification of the tutorial and that
starts it just like the hyperlink did in
my previous example so this is a nice
way if you're if you're an author and
you want to test and iterate on a
tutorial this gives you the ability to
do that right from the console that's
pretty much it I also wanted to point
you to the documentation which you can
find under cloud.google.com slash l /
Doc's slash tutorials and there you can
find more details about formatting your
markdown and all of the different
capabilities that are available that
those special features I mentioned for
integrating your tutorial with the with
the console or the cloud shell
environment so that's it I hope you
enjoyed that I hope this gave you a
sense for some of the powerful things
you can do in authoring these tutorials
in in the Google cloud environment
Thanks